hi welcome to another episode of not too
deep I'm your host grace Helbig and
today we have rclbeauty101 you know her
as Rachel we talk about all kinds of
things she's been a beauty guru on
YouTube for a decade what's that like
her new beauty line her new music career
I also learned her obsession with the
Sims is a real obsession and she owns a
llama farm you know that's just thrown
in there for good measure amongst all
the other things she's doing hear all
about it on this episode of not too deep
with our sale beauty Rachel's here this
is very exciting
Rachel how long have you officially been
in the YouTube world hmm oh my goodness
how long since I was 15 so I'm 24 now so
like nine years turning 25 like next
week though Wow so you almost lost 10
2010 do you remember your first video
that you uploaded of course showing
people how to conceal under eye dark
circles well I did it wrong okay
comments very quickly taught me that I
did it wrong what compelled you to
upload that video I hated everyone in my
high school cuz they just weren't nice
yeah so I was like I would spend a lot
of time just watching YouTube videos
yeah it's the point where I do like
makeup tutorials in the mirror every
morning sure sure I was like I have a
problem I should probably just like do a
makeup tutorial yeah and I just don't
don't like my computer's like the iSight
camera yeah just upload it I didn't
think anything to come of it obviously
because I was 15 and YouTube wasn't
really like much of a thing it was just
this fun little site that people posted
things on yeah yeah that's crazy so 10
years ago you're 15 you upload a video
did your family no no no okay we honest
no but the way that my mom found out
granted I told her I was like I think
after uploading it like four days later
or something the video had 457 views
uh-huh that's how it's my mom was like
mom my video is part reviews interviews
she was like what video Rachel I was
like I'm gonna keep you up to date here
mom let me
some information here yes but that also
like 10 years ago so we're talking 2010
mm-hmm that is such a different space
than what YouTube is in right now
yeah and you've been consistently
uploading videos for 10 years mm-hmm are
you exhausted is anybody not exhausted
you've been doing it from same yeah
that's why I like talking to people I've
been doing it for so long that I'm like
can't we just be tired I'm so tired I
don't sleep well that's a-ok
I'm very curious I have more kind of
like insider technical questions for you
about everything I got all the answers
well because looking through like your
whole you know archive of videos they're
very intense a lot of them they're very
like ambitious like thesis statements
and what you're gonna do like 24 hours
of anything is too much yeah I learned
that two weeks ago yeah so you've been
doing a bunch of 24 hour videos for the
last like couple years or year or so
yeah like year so I did I did the the 24
hours in like the quicksand or kinetics
and yeah that one is a claustrophobia
nightmare no I was outside still
anything piled on me for 24 hours is
nightmarish to me how did that were you
just like this is a great idea
everyone's into kinetics and what if I
just live in it for 24 hours that's
literally exactly my thought process
it's like I might as well it's already
here and how do you even go about like
producing that kind of video well first
because I didn't want to spend $30,000
on kinetic sand right
I had my producer at the time just
contact like every kinetic sand company
right and ask for 5,000 pounds of it
granted easy no one company said yes Wow
I was like we're in so what did whether
anything or any learning lessons from
that video yeah I threw out the hot tub
after that I was like I'm not doing
these hot tub videos grid said I I like
did a bunch of hot tub videos when I
still live in Philadelphia at my mom's
house uh-huh
but it broke the hot tub so that's
that's understandable you would never
think that putting 10 million oil reason
it would have any effect whatsoever but
yeah after I broke my mom's the the one
that I bought after that for California
was a pre broken one so I couldn't break
it oh that's smart that's also a hack
way back by broken things for videos but
then after that I just got like like
burnt out of that style video and I was
like I can't do it anymore like I hate
the idea of doing these they make me
want to cry yeah I mean looking through
like your whole archive in your
catalogue of videos I'm like this
stresses me out a little bit like how
grand the scale is of this it also must
be a pressure that once you do a 24 hour
thing once that everyone's like do it
bigger and better next time yeah if I
don't listen to those people but good
for you yeah that was a big thing I've
learned how to do it's not yeah that um
I feel like it's always easier said than
done
but at some point you reach like a
breaking point I'm just not giving a
care about the way people talk to you
online
absolutely cuz I mean over ten years
you've probably got in every single
comment about every single thing about
you yes the Internet is a very fun place
it's very fun and awful at the same time
but you still kept doing 24 hour videos
you've done 24 hour makeup you did your
makeup for 24 hours straight that was
the most recent I'm not doing another
time for our video good for you yes I
did too and now I'm like mmm done that's
the max that's maxed out yeah how do you
even record for 24 hours straight is it
just constantly recharging batteries re
plugging everything in so I have
probably like 20 batteries always on it
like ready like charged up and like a
bunch of memory cards like I think I
like 60 memory hurts charged up Wow
good for you I love buying things in
bulk and I love it
it's the worst though at the same time
because I'll buy things in bulk before I
even know if I like them like my shampoo
I'm like yeah this is gonna be good if
you gamble it's such an issue because
now my body wash I'm like ah I'm not
into this but I have 16 more bottles
yeah it's it's just it's a prop my mom's
always bought every
- like the second I was like I think I
like ranch dressing on my french fries
the whole cabinet is killed by dressing
my grandma does it - I went to her house
there was like the entire freezer like
full of Junior Mints I was like wow it's
hereditary you know I didn't even
realize it until I just said it right
now it has to be it's a learned behavior
you can't blame yourself
I never did the also yeah I was just
watching that you went to Tokyo or you
went to Japan to buy makeup did that
really happen did it yes that's so you
that I stayed in Japan for longer okay
okay yeah I was gonna say this seems a
little like you say extra to go you
threw a dart at a map it landed on Japan
and you went there and you bought makeup
yes and you play it off like it's the
most casual trip to CBS that you've done
it's like all in editing yeah okay I was
like this I I can barely put on a camera
and talk about fashion and you're going
to Japan yeah also I'm really glad that
we have you here today because I know
today is a big day because you're at the
time that we're recording this at
midnight tonight your first song comes
out that's very exciting are you nervous
are you stuffing down all of the anxiety
um I don't think so I think I'm a little
like traumatized from launch as though
because with the makeup brand launch
yeah I was like that's such a small team
Oh should I pause no no well so for the
makeup brand launch it was just like me
my manager and my film producer okay
like getting everything in theater like
taking all the photos to the website and
everything because we like contacted Lee
we were gonna have like a whole like one
of those like product photographers or
fancy schmancy and they quoted it's like
$40,000 for a photo shoot for the
website and I was like Zak get on over
here yeah and then he taught me how to
edit in Photoshop so he took half the
photos I took half the photos and I
didn't know how to edit photos like that
so he was such like a small team and we
didn't sleep and we had like there was
maybe like two nights during that week
we're like randomly one of us would just
start crying a good lunch that boswell
it was so good like a lot of the people
that we
for it but we hired like a publicist and
all these things right didn't like they
didn't do anything really yeah and then
after the launch once they didn't do
anything like they were like oh we just
won't charge you I was like you you owe
me money at this point I would have had
so much publicity on this it's just like
so like kind of traumatized from that
for the song launch now even though I
have like the most phenomenal music team
like I feel so confident with them like
I feel like sighted and exhilarated
about my music career that's great but
also it's such a pivot because I feel
and tell me if I'm wrong that you music
hasn't been a part or hasn't been shown
and you haven't sang or you haven't
really expressed that much interest in
it so it sort of feels like it's coming
out of nowhere
so that was my plan okay six years ago I
decided well I've always sung since I
was like three but I decided like six
years ago like I'm gonna release a song
but then I was also like but I'm not
gonna tell you what about it okay ever
except for there was one slip-up in like
2014 I did a Black Friday haul where
there was like one small section where I
saying and it was what we were you can
do that yeah so I've been like making
sure not to ever show me singing because
I want it to be a shock that's what you
want okay I love shock yeah I can barely
tell by the types of videos that you do
that you love a big impact I love it so
that's really cool but that also must be
a little difficult to like keep under
wraps for so long
impossible I've had to edit me singing
out of so many videos cuz I'll just be
like walking to the house like
constantly singing like I just don't
ever stop like like it's an issue like a
lot of my friends are like like okay can
you stop like if you're gonna do it can
you at least finish the whole song like
can you stop singing that one part I'm
like I'm so sorry this is a me problem
apologize yes but that's so that's nuts
and so when this release is because this
episode will come out after the music is
launched and everything is it is the
goal an album is the go on EP I don't
know the difference I know nothing about
music the goal so I'm currently working
on the whole EP right now okay but yeah
it's an EP which i think is like five to
six songs
something cool but I don't want to say
what it's about cousin I said someone
else might take it you don't say what
it's about I understand that you like to
keep everything very secretive until the
public gets to see it is there can you
describe the style of music for the holy
Pierre for the one song um I'm still
learning my style of music okay um but I
know I like it uh like like who are your
influences ah
there's so many uh I had to make this
thing called a soundscape because I'm
trying to like explain to my singing
coach my style of music and he's like I
I don't know what you're talking about
like that is the most unclear thing ever
I was like ah so I made a soundscape
which is like where you take like 40
songs and take like five - like seven
seconds parts of the songs that you like
and edit those together that's cool so
I'm still learning I mean it's
definitely pop okay okay but pop also
apparently like just means popular music
so I don't know if it's actually it like
it I like cuz pop technically in like
2001 wasn't like punk rock so it's like
I don't know what even entails anymore
yeah I feel like there's sub genres
within pop as a as a giant genre mm-hmm
so--but but also it seems like you're
getting into it so you're finding your
voice while you're making your music
I've probably made like 30 songs at this
point that I'm not releasing Wow yeah so
you do so much secretive stuff I love
doing second there's like someone I was
talking to my uh like somebody that I'm
working on in an app with okay another
secret project another secret project
and when I was talking I was like can we
just like wait a second because he had
so we had to pause working on the app
for like two months while I was figuring
out the makeup brand launch like even
all of that and then so he knew he
couldn't like contact me during that cuz
I was to like tunnel vision a friend and
the other day he text me trying to set
up a meeting and I was like I'm sorry
could we just wait till after the 14th
he's like why I was like that's when the
songs really saying I think I'll have
more time after he was like a song you
really sent a song and I was like oh
yeah sorry yeah I am he was like wow
okay
well hopefully I can get you in before
the you you film your next movie and I
was like see we're filming this year
they're like he said
obviously yeah it's about the book that
I wrote about yeah just all this stuff
just word vomits out of you now but I
think that's so fascinating because in
the YouTube world it's everyone is very
transparent you know everyone's hinting
at and talking about and you know
putting out there everything that
they're kind of working on and then
there's like the side where it's like
secret project can tell you about this
thing and you seem to really hold
everything close to the chest well I
also know that there's two reasons for
that one I have like the worst time
management skills so I don't want people
to think like the song was supposed to
launch in November okay and we kept
pushing it like a push like three times
until we officially got February 14th
where we needed it to be so it's like
the song was originally unwashed I don't
want to disappoint people with a bunch
of future launch dates Rea but also like
I'm just after being on the internet for
so long like I really hold privacy is
like a big thing like I'll like I'll be
broken up with somebody for like six
months before I'll tell subscribers
about it yeah no I saw that and I
thought that's really interesting that
it's I respect that a lot the ability to
have restraint of like showing so much
of your personal life yeah in real time
too yeah which made the makeup brand
launch even harder because it was like
as I was going through a breakup with
Tyler so it was like ah the makeup brand
launched and I'm going for breakup which
no one know that yeah yeah and like even
like with my first boyfriend like the
day that I liked that we broke up was
like the morning that I had like an ad
week cover shoot so like I like
would go to like I went to the photo
shoot would be like in between looks I
go to the bathroom cry go back out like
smile with my makeup on like take photos
for the head like the cover shoot
but that I mean I think that's great
because I think one of the traps that a
lot of people can fall into is you know
revealing so much of themselves online
and then that's all people want to know
about that's all people focus on so when
you do have project so you do have like
products come out then people aren't
paying attention to that they're like
but tell us more about the break-up yeah
yeah which i think is great to kind of
shift the focus and keep it on like what
you like doing I also think it's like
not fair to like the other people
involved to be thrown into something
that they didn't really sign the mental
contract of being thrown into yeah I'm
just like I also like to expand drama
and like just like keep it very like
keep it moving yeah but I think that's
great because the beauty world which I'm
I'm obviously not a part of but I'm
fascinated by endlessly there's so much
drama in that world and it didn't used
to be that way yeah at least as far as I
understood didn't and now I feel like
it's it's like gaining momentum based on
these drama fueled situation hmm and it
must be hard to stay out of all of it or
it's easy well I find that the way to
stay out of drama is just not respond
when somebody tries to start drama yeah
that's a skill that a lot of youtubers
don't have it's hard because like you
want to respond to it right you want to
be like I want to defend myself but a
big thing that I like live by is like
there's no need to justify yourself
because the ones that love you won't
need it and the ones that hate you won't
believe it so there's no reason to like
even try is this in your book that
you're writing or honeymoon or a trilogy
who knows what's down the pipe it's like
a story book it's not like a story up
it's not like a book about me it's like
a cute like like 12 year old
businesswoman boss - she female dogs you
know all right yeah it's it's cuz you're
you're in that world and you're friends
with everyone and everyone likes it you
know yeah insert their point of view for
better or worse so it must be it must
also be kind of fun to sit on the
sidelines and just sort of watch it
happen it's it's not fun when you see
the person's mental health getting
affected by it he's like I'll be like
sitting down with one of my friends then
they'll like be reading things about
them that of people are saying and then
doble kidding me like this is so messed
up that they're saying this and I'm like
dang like you don't see that part when
like yeah yeah so I always feel like
so bad that this situation is happening
especially because none of them ever
really like do anything to deserve it
it just kind everything's just like
misconstrued from everything that
everyone says because they love hating
people
oh it said well it is an epidemic yeah
people love hating people
it's very okay it could paralyze you in
terms of like putting anything on the
internet because you're like this is
gonna get scrutinized from every single
angle possible that I even realized
angles were available to be scrutinized
yeah yeah that's why I just don't
respond to anything cuz that's one tries
scrutinizing and it's like the ones I
love you won't need it the ones I hate
you won't put that on a pillow I'll
sleep on it it sounds wonderful
okay we're gonna take a quick break when
we get back I want to talk about the
makeup line I want to talk about the
launch of it because again it seems like
another project that was in your brain
rattling around for years and years and
then all the sudden here it is it'll be
right back with more not you D Erin
Gibson author of feminist E and host of
the throwing shade podcast I love that
podcast has a new podcast history the
chic we'll celebrating forgotten female
heroes each week Erin is joined by a
cool teen co-host to learn about a slice
of her story that time and your history
class ignored from the first female
astronaut trainees to abandon Apache
warriors to science fiction innovators
and even pirates ville femme splain
yesteryear because the future is female
and so was the past come celebrate
Women's History Month this March and
broaden your historical knowledge with
history this chic will you can listen to
history the chic will on stitcher Apple
podcast or wherever you listen
starting March 2nd okay let's talk about
the makeup line Arklow am I saying that
right yes you are okay this was
something that you was in the works for
what like four years or something yeah I
think I started it in 2015
yes 2015 okay so talk me through
how this happened so how it actually
happened which nobody knows this part so
like if you had a secret I know I came
up with this product that didn't exist
yet like called an eyeliner stamp where
you can like stamp the eyeliner wing on
- oh okay so I was very Shark Tank yeah
I was working on developing that there
was no patents there it wasn't like a
thing so I was talking to different
patent lawyers and they were like
there's no point in you making that like
there's no point of you getting a patent
on this until the products made because
every single time you change something
you're gonna have to reget them a new
patent okay blah blah so like I was like
okay fine I'll make the product first
and then I'll get the patent of the
product
uh-huh I really wanted to release this
fake because I was obsessed with DIYs at
the time like I was like how does not
exist like it's gonna make everyone's
day so much faster yeah and then as I
was working on it when I finally got the
product where I wanted it to be some
other brand came out with like a an OK
version of that product I'm not exactly
what I wanted but like similar enough
that I was like great every makeup
brands not to be on top of this and
copying that one right acting it until
it's like basically what I have yeah so
I had to throw out that product and not
do eggs yeah and then I came up with
another product that I might still
release who knows like didn't you do
anything no one knows yeah exactly so
it's like it's then that product was
released so I keep inventing these new
products that like somehow keep getting
released before me I'm like convinced
there's someone listening yeah and like
your house is bugged it might be yeah
but so then those products have coming
out so like the brand story was
originally like super innovative makeup
that doesn't exist and then all the
innovative products I was making kept
being released by other people and I'm
like how did you even get the patent
that fast my patent lawyer wouldn't even
let me do it yeah so like the brand
story had to change a lot so then I like
we switched it around then I just
started making products that I just
would really want in my daily routine
mhm
so we like took a really long time
developing that but the brand like
started something we were completely
different because the people that I was
working with originally kept being like
okay so why don't you just go into a
showroom and pick products off the shelf
and I was like because then they're not
me then they're just products that exist
and everyone else already has them
because
people generally do like they'll walk
into a showroom and pick things off the
shelf and then just put it into a line
and then develop the formula a little
bit okay so they basically pick
pre-existing products add a little
something-something to the formula put
their own packaging on it and call it
their own yeah and I didn't want to do
that because yeah just uh doesn't feel
as special to me sure so I wanted to
develop things from scratch and
unfortunately when you do that it takes
like four years really to make them yeah
I mean making the products took a second
and then once you get lawyers involved
talking like lawyers take forever yeah
anything I love like my mom's a lawyer
but like the fact that she's a lawyer
sucks because lawyers are just so like
slow and then they talk and lingo that I
don't understand yeah it's a different
language it's so hard like they're just
like so beyond my intelligence level
yeah both I can't comprehend anything
that they're saying it's frustrating too
because you know that they can come down
to your level but they just choose not
to and my guy can you please just
translate in the most layman's terms for
me what this means yeah they won't do
that won't do that so like it took like
two years to negotiate contracts Wow
so the launch was supposed to happen
again which is why I'm happy I didn't
talk about the launch right before cuz
the launch was supposed to happen every
single season for two years I kept
changing the colors I was like a spring
roll launching in spring here's the
spring color oh we're on to the fall
color a winter winter color so like yeah
that must be tough because you're almost
predicting like not necessarily trends
but you're predicting you know
seasonally what people want to buy when
there's a like you have to be so far in
advance to see like what people are
people still wearing eye shadow or is
everyone doing just lips right now
luckily there's like the the makeup
brand like the team there in the
creative like I love the creative team
for the makeup brand like I always feel
so like excited whenever I like talked
about me but um they're really good at
know in those things so like they go to
every single Fashion Week thing like
they find the colors the Pantone so
they're closed the year like they they
really know those types of things um
when it pertains to products we were
originally gonna come out with a liquid
lipstick and not a lip gloss huh well we
were gonna come off the lip gloss
in spring like for future launch but we
weren't gonna come out with it for their
original launch but liquid lipsticks are
not as much of a thing anymore yeah so
it's like we already had to switch
things and like because we weren't doing
liquid lipsticks we couldn't do a lip
liner because it's like who puts lip
gloss on on a lip liner oh well some
people probably do but I did not so
right that's my brand I didn't do it and
like originally the eyeshadows weren't
even an eye shadow like compact it was
like individual shadows because that's
what was doing really well when I first
started right coold like an individual
eye shadow compact but then nobody's
buying individual eyeshadows anymore so
we switched it to a palette so it's just
like everything's just such moving
pieces but it's it's now that it's out
like I get to like just go which is
exciting that's great and all and it
also must be stressful behind the scenes
because makeup launches especially by
like influencers are so scrutinized and
like quality is like the first thing
that everyone's like looking at because
everyone's ready to cancel you if
there's like a tiny hair in something
how did you get to the point where you
felt like super confident about like the
quality of the product will the people
that I work with for making the makeup
products like I fully trust like they
they helped start up like two-faced and
like start up like it cosmetics like a
small brand they just like do such good
work yeah and like they make such good
quality products which is why I worked
with them because I was like they're
phenomenal what they do so even if it's
like like there's so many like I know
for a fact they're gonna make things
good mm-hmm so I wasn't worried about
the quality on that end and then if
anybody said anything about like bad
about like the product or the quality
like the only people that have ever said
anything even slightly bad about it have
been people that have never tried the
products never touch the products
they're like fun oh it looks cheap I'm
like actually if you hold it in person
like looks super high-quality yeah touch
it yeah exactly so it's like no one
that's been a reputable source has said
anything that is like negative about the
products interesting yeah so like I know
they're good even like they're the
information I'm getting from people that
are reputable sources as in people that
have tried the products or like they're
there so like high quality there so like
all those good things but it's great
that's what it's like I know yeah how
have you felt since the launch oh the
worst okay yeah I'd uh I don't sleep
is it just because you're concerned
about people enjoying the product or is
it just because it's like it's out there
now it's it is honestly it has nothing
to do with the products or the things
because I make up friends doing like
super well right now it's just like
apparently being a CEO is completely
different than being a youtuber yeah
what would you say it's the main
difference there are a lot of people
that are expecting a lot of answers for
me but I don't have yet like so it's
like it ah I just don't know what to
like tell them right like they're all
like there's like a whole team's of
people looking to me to give them
answers and I'm like I'm gonna be over
here in this kinetic sand for a little
bit you can come back when I'm ready
yeah so I just guess I just assumed like
this was just bold of me to assume but I
assumed when you're the CEO you kind of
just were like you go yes I proved
approved right really you don't you're
gonna be in everything so look I don't
sleep on that end and then also working
on the song I don't sleep on that end
and then I don't sleep on the YouTube
end yeah I mean do you is everything
still other than like the the teams that
you have around you for the products and
launches is everything still like a
small production for you it's a um like
I have this problem where I don't
delegate anything to anybody else
yes I'm like well if anyone else is
gonna do it like I can do it better and
I can do it the way I wanted so like why
would I have other people do it which is
making it so hard like I just for the
first time hired an editor and she's
edited like like one video as good an
edited everything else though I know I
like literally there's a very good step
it's very hard I feel like that's a
common like commonality that all people
that create content have is
control issues over their own stuff cuz
it's you it's all you at the end of the
day mm-hmm yeah so to give it to someone
else I get it I get like the nervousness
and anxiety of being of like hoping that
they can do what you have in your head
yeah and the issue that is like I'll
have like the most talented people
around me but I have such poor
communication skills when it pertains to
getting what I want out of my head
uh-huh so I'll be like no you gotta do
it like this and they do it like that
and I'm like oh so when I said that I
didn't mean this I meant that like I
didn't know how to work out so they do
that and then they just start getting
frustrated so it's just like a lot of
learning curves
I hate learning things like that like I
love learning like I love when things
happen in the life that forced me to
learn right like yeah trust me I want to
be at the end game of it I want to
already have all these skill sets and
know how to fully function in a world
but I think it's helpful to know that it
is a little messy getting through all of
it that from the outside I think people
could look and be like oh she's got
everything figured out she does
everything mapped out everything planned
out does it look like that yeah a little
bit but but it's nice and it's quirky
and relatable to hear that it is like a
process to figure all of it out the same
way like YouTube was a process to figure
out that you're like I don't I'm blindly
throwing myself on to this platform
without knowing what it is and now I'm
gonna kind of figure out things here and
there as we go do you what do you do for
fun yeah yeah okay I have this problem
which I feel like this is like it's
because like my mom's a lawyer my dad's
a doctor but such businesspeople like I
got my business of such professionals I
got my business census from them so I'm
like a workaholic like they're the most
workaholic people I know and I'm the
child of the work most workaholic people
I know you're their product yeah so I'm
like double workaholic than anyone I
know
so I have this issue where every single
time I find a hobby I turn it into a
career path so it's like it I love it
like I love like figuring out things
like it's so fun figure everything but
it's like even when I like finally for a
second I was like I have a hobby of like
playing The Sims then I was like I love
playing The Sims this is great
and I was like
I'm gonna send this channel like no no
don't channel happening but then I had
to update my computer uh-huh and
apparently Sims 3 wasn't able to be run
on that update so I had to literally
like what do you do
I chose between YouTube in the Sims and
I chose youtube because I needed to be
able to edit in the final cut because it
wouldn't open up final cut because
[Music]
hearing I'm just thinking about it I put
so much time like that sim um which I
also think is funny like that's a Maya
like you know how like you're Simmons
like your little dream world yeah and I
don't play it but I understand the
combination and it's dangerous yeah I
feel like it can be a dark Hall it is
but I like made my sim work 24/7 I like
it I bought her one of those mood things
so I can always make it so she's always
like full and like hygiene like hygiene
like always like like never stressed so
that she could always be like I was like
yeah if I make her paint I can sell
these paintings for $2000 huge I bought
the entire city the entire city was
owned by mice and like she's ready to
settle down
I'll have her settle down now I created
her the perfect specimen to breed with
so she can make beautiful children that
specimen like the guy that I created for
her he was on The Sims world for at
least like a month on his own just
living on his own I moved him in next
door
you know kicked out the goth family
moved and then for one like after I
finally got him to like I got her to
propose to him because I was like this
guy's not doing anything this is like
just like existing yeah um after that
happened and he moved in I realized this
sim did not get a job this entire time I
was like how is she going to breed with
this lazy like so I was I had to like so
she had every single skill in the entire
Sims world like she was this like the
most athletic the best cook like the
best like at writing shoe it had
everything like everything was sim could
be she
yeah so then the guy sim didn't know
anything he didn't learn a single skill
this entire time of being on the Sims
world but sometimes opposites attract
no I taught them I taught him every
single skill that she had i sat her down
and made her tutor him because I didn't
want to use any cheats because then it's
not fun right here using cheats it's not
organic that's not real love
no I my sim didn't use any cheats and I
wouldn't let the guy simply use any
cheats either but yeah so her goal was
to be so did the CEO of a mega
corporation okay so then I got my sim
without any cheats to be worth over 2
million simoleons Wow and then I'd had
to delete it and I realized I have a
problem because I make my dream world
work I mean how long has it been since
you've played maybe like 2 or 3 months
okay I mean are you itching to play
again I think it's a dangerous path I
did I would get the newer Sims that I
can always play it mm-hmm and I think at
that point I would just use cheats to
get the sim back to where my sim was to
create my sims world wait so now that
you're not playing that world just
disappears
yeah oh that's sad yeah that's tragic
but also I guess that's like real life
you know laying the game then everything
goes away
wow that's that's dark but maybe I
should get into the sims for a little
bit
other than Sims anything you do could
you watch TV movies yeah have you ever
heard a show called 30 rock it's a
really good yes I have it's a great show
yeah I just started watching that well
there you go how are you gonna monetize
it I'm gonna try my best not to okay I
mean the show review no no yeah I can
see you all of a sudden yesterday you've
started a review channel of 30 rock
every episode this is very outdated
it means a lot to me um do you tick-tock
I have a tick-tock I don't often
tick-tock because I'm I have so many
other things going on yeah
I don't know who where to find the time
to like tick-tock yeah I don't I don't I
also have a tick-tock I have no idea how
to use it I was gonna ask you for tips
but I don't know
cool I put some video of my dog it seems
to do well I posted this really cute
video of my dog when I was like I took
his toy and then he just looked really
upset so I took the camera out as a good
parent and then when I was like I'm
sorry for taking your toy and then he
was like just looked at me upset and
then I was like I can give you your toy
then he was like so I posted that on
tik-tok and that one did well okay
posted on Twitter too and Seth Rogen
liked that tweet Wow I know I'm famous
now suddenly I mean I don't know but I'm
expecting a clothing swap with Seth
Rogen I wish I if you could do a
clothing swap with a celebrity like who
would be your ideal guest in one of
those types of videos every time like
dream celebrity are we talking like
realistic let's do both um dream
celebrity would be like like Rihanna or
like Kylie Jenner oh yeah those would be
great and realistic realities fake so it
doesn't even matter
anything's possible I'm Eric Riley Jenna
yeah I think those are realistic
celebrities that you could get in a
clothing swap video that'd be fun I
would love to see it has anything ever
gone I've ever not posted a video
because something's gone like
horrendously wrong um the only time I've
ever not posted a video it's not that it
goes horrendously wrong but it's more my
values change like I one time in 2016
was the last time I've ever filmed a
video that I didn't post because I'm so
strategic whenever I like planning out
my video list that all the videos that I
have played out I'm like do you know
you're gonna do them yeah so I did a
video in 2016 where I filmed how to get
rid of stretch marks fast and I was like
okay cool
I'll teach people how to get rid of
stretch marks and then I edited it and
then I was like what's wrong with
stretch marks oh oh yeah and then I was
like why would I be trying to teach with
letting get rid of them when they're
just like these cool lightning bolt
things on your body
why what I try to point that as
something that should be changed on
people so it was like I'm trashing this
video there's no way I'm posting well
it's good for you because I think that's
also something that doesn't get
considered a ton and like the beauty
world that it's like toeing the line
between embracing and celebrating like
makeup and beauty and then also like
giving room to be accepting of all these
like you know quirks and things and
uniqueness about the human body yeah
absolutely
that's very cool and also kudos to you
in 2016 for having that we're about to
do that thank you
Tana mojo tweeted that you offered her a
lemongrass scented refrigerated wet
towel from Vietnam when she came over is
that true hi love lemongrass essential
oil towels I bought I went to Vietnam
for my birthday last year and they gave
me one and I was like who's this they're
like - lemongrass essential oil tallow
and I was like how do you make these and
then she was like I just put like like
essential oil and said I didn't know
what that meant
so I like googled it and then I bought
like five mini fridges put them in every
bathroom of my house bought like a ton
of little mini face towels from Amazon
you can get like a huge pack of like 50
for like 6 bucks
there's your bulk yes and then I just
every single like once a week I would
make them you can roll them up yes or
like pick up a hot water bowl two drops
of lemongrass essential oil uh-huh mix
it up with your hands put the towel and
squeeze the towel peel it up put it in
the mini fridge let it cool and then
wait till 10 a mojo comes to the house
it's a trap it's a bougie beautiful trap
but also it seems pretty easy to do oh
my god it's so easy and also I've
learned that when you set your mind
isn't thank you fully do it yeah but I
recently stopped because I noticed that
I wasn't having as many people over at
the house so like the house would just
sit there Raiders full of wet towels and
nobody would be taking them so it's like
until I become a social butterfly again
which I don't see happening for a decent
amount of time because the only reason I
ever
people over at my house in the first
place because my ex Tyler was such a
social butterfly so like he would always
have people over and I'd be like yeah
I'm gonna host
let me grab some towels but now I don't
host people I just kind of and if I do
host people it's like my close friends
who like will both just like be sitting
in like in our underwear just hanging
out yeah they don't care about getting
towels
I mean I'll come over and take a towel I
won't hang it make you uncomfortable but
I'll do that too I have a guest room now
done I mean I always had a guest room
but now I got a bed in it an official
guest room yeah how many parking tickets
do you think you've gathered in your
life like actually mm-hmm I literally
got one like three days ago probably
like if we're being honest probably like
nine or ten but I didn't start driving
until I was 18
mm-hmm cuz I'm so impatient that I
didn't want to wait the six months
between like getting your learner's
permit your license so I was like I'm
gonna do it all at once so I got I think
I got my learner's permit and I license
all within like four days you know what
that doesn't surprise me about you okay
we're gonna take one last break I'm
gonna get back we have some Twitter
questions for you so we'll be right back
with we're not your date today we have
support from light box if you like
diamonds if you like bling if you like
walking into the room and having the
reflection of your aura shine on
everyone then this might be the thing
for you light box makes gorgeous
lab-grown diamonds which are essentially
chemically the same as natural ones
except they're made in a lab to make
them they put a tiny piece of lab-grown
diamond into a plasma reactor and heat
it up to temperatures almost as hot as
the Sun science I don't fully understand
it but it's science and then in about
two weeks the seed turns into a full
carat stone every stone is made the same
every time so they're also priced the
same every time at $800 per carat
they've even cracked the science of
creating gorgeous gems in pink and blue
so treat yourself to a little sparkle
you earned it
go to lightbox jewelry comm slash Grace
and use code grace for $25 off again
that's lightbox jewelry dot-com slash
grace and use code grace for $25 off
we're back with more not too deep okay
Rachel before we get into these Twitter
questions I'm gonna ask you the two
questions asked every single guest okay
that is on the podcast and the first is
who alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti at so like this is
assuming that people think of being
thrown cold spaghetti is a negative
thing correct it's entirely your
intention so it can be celebratory my
little sister okay I would absolutely
throw cold spaghetti at her why is that
I love cold spaghetti oh so it would be
like a sign of love I mean if I can
clone myself and throw cold spaghetti at
myself I would that's an option too yeah
fill a hot tub with it fill my YouTube
video wow it's automatic
okay the other question is every single
guest on the podcast is it tell us your
worst pants shooting story or close call
but you can only use three words or
three small phrases so mine for instance
is in college
jogging front lawn like you've actually
almost pooped your pants oh I did I
don't think I've ever pooped my pants
before or you can be a close call it
doesn't have to be it can be at number
one scenario I have repeat myself well I
wore pull-ups until I was like 11 okay I
can count but you have to use three
words or three small phrases to tell us
any story that you know might have been
a special scenario huh I've never
thought about this before I don't think
I have as many like bathroom issues is
the standard person I guess I mean kudos
to you you think you know I mean it just
took 11 years of peeing the bed every
night
like really get to that point of my life
I guess I guess I'll do mmm
sleeping uh-huh God baby sleeping
sleeping sleeping dreaming water okay
dreaming like every single time I pee
the bed when I was younger I would like
always be like you would dream about a
water like I'd be like swimming or
something like that and that's when like
she would come it's all of a
subconscious I guess what I knew I was
peeing I remember like when I'd be like
sleeping in my dreams I'm like I you did
it again
oh that's that must have been a true fun
time well I once I figured out the whole
pull-ups thing it wasn't an issue
anymore when would the get on the bed
it'd be an issue but like it was always
fun like waking up ruining filling up
the sink sitting in it shower
you know the stresses of being 11 years
old and under just really get questions
someone to know do you ever feel burned
out on YouTube like have you ever taken
breaks or a time off um I definitely
took a break with this recent breakup
mm-hmm like I didn't upload as much but
I didn't tell people why but I did
it's okay I you know what it seems like
I take a break whenever I'm going
through a breakup I think that's healthy
yeah I think that's good mm-hmm then you
can handle it privately it doesn't have
to be a public like yeah you know
situation yeah but I also fully intend
on never ever dating anybody again and
not getting married so like okay that's
your best line all right I mean and when
you set your mind to something you
really do I tell I was talking to my dad
the other day and I was like um yeah
like I'm never gonna get married he was
like why wouldn't you get married
love is like such an amazing thing I was
like not for me I focused too much on
the other person I'm gonna just love
myself
that's good that's a good major takeaway
hmm um but do you ever feel burned out
do you feel like pressure to have to
keep making videos like do you see
yourself making videos forever um I get
burned out uh I mean I wouldn't say it's
burned out but I'll have like times
where I just can't feel creative sure
where I'm like like I'll be like sitting
down for like days trying to come up
with a video idea and I'm like I I'm
just not feeling it right now so I'll
have like times where I'm like I'll have
to skip it up a little because I was
like I'd rather just skip a week then
put out something that I'm not like out
of or something yeah um so yeah I would
say let's burn out more writer's block I
mean I'm probably currently burnt out
but like I push every feeling to the
back of my head so it's like I don't I
don't know about it you compartmentalize
it's probably in a compartment back
there somewhere you know like yeah my
favorite we need to stop doing that but
what does she know yeah someone to know
what's something unexpected that you're
really into or very knowledgeable about
I have a llama farm excuse you you have
a llama farm yeah I have a llama farm
I'm pretty knowledgeable about farms you
where is your llama farm West Virginia
okay is this like a family-owned no I
bought it myself
you bought it yourself I'd like 30
llamas and they're currently in West
Virginia roaming roaming they're having
a great time how often do you go back
there I have not gone to it once oh okay
so you are the benefactor of this llama
farm in West Virginia and you've never
visited it I know I am yeah yeah I have
this farmer named Josh who takes really
good care of the llamas okay what work
drove you to buy a llama farm why not
yes and where do you search for the
availability of a llama farm my mom
helped me with that oh yeah we also like
will go to like well when I say I mean
Josh the farmer will go to like
different llama auctions and like
purchase the most like high quality like
just like the
best in the show llamas that we can
breed them and make perfect mama babies
Wow because apparently with llamas like
it's very like a Kalama with blue eyes
isn't worth as much as a llama with like
brown eyes like this is a very specific
like you know how there's social
standards for humans just stupid there's
like even worse ones for llamas I had no
idea it's horrible and I feel horrible
for the llamas but you're providing a
beautiful home for some of them for some
of the beautiful ones I pre messed up
actually why don't you reverse this this
thesis statement and start housing all
the ones that are a little less
desirable you know I'd put as much like
time and effort into a llama farm as
that like I think I got to focus more on
like helping adjust that with humanity
before I start to yeah well that's I
mean that goes into this next question
someone to know what's the stupidest
thing about beauty standards the fact
that llamas that have blue eyes I did
not know I was gonna learn today I
appreciate that the stupidest thing
about beauty standards is that it
changed they change all the time like
the fact that like my eyebrows were
really in style like two years ago and
now they're just not it's just like the
fact that body parts can become a trend
is just so stupid a strange you just
ended you're just dumb honestly like we
should just throw them all away like
what what is this like if you look at a
picture of somebody that was like the
perfect human like in the 1900s it'd be
like completely different the perfect
human now because the perfect human
doesn't exist it's a fake thing so
beauty standards themselves are like
useless like I can't wait to like
they're just gone because they're so
dumb I agree I agree
someone's no what was the hardest part
about launching your makeup brand all of
it okay the most fun part was the
creating it but everything else just
because I because when I was going
through the breakup was when I was
talking to Mike who's the other like
co-owner well not co-owner like but like
he owns percentage of it when I was
talking to him I was like having a phone
call like with him and my manager like I
was sitting at the table and I remember
being like hey okay so when do you think
we shall launch the makeup brand because
I was hoping cuz I wanted to push it to
like
where's my cuz again going through a
breakup and then he was like we're gonna
launch it
December 16th and I was like why and
then he was like we want to go before
the holidays and I was like so like I'm
definitely not in a good mental place so
I launched the makeup brand right now
yeah there's just like a lot happening
right now but I guess I can technically
double up my therapy sessions maybe and
then we can launch the makeup brand he
was like perfect let's do that and I was
like I thought that he was gonna say no
let's not do that but he didn't know
like nobody knew I was going with the
break-up I don't I didn't tell even like
my best friends didn't know oh wow we're
keeping it really really really really
really secret yeah which is tough and
also like you know when you want to be
professional it's hard to manage like
where to spend your mental energy and
how much time to take off when sometimes
focusing on work and distracting
yourself is helpful sometimes not it was
a it was just a lot because it was you
know it was like a three year long
relationship
it was just like like then also having
to like like officially start up a
company like he was like starting up
some wires but like he was just it was
just a lot like I just wasn't like
mentally able to like yeah really be
there so I was just like constantly like
I'd be like working all the time and
like consoling just pushing things to
the back of my head until like it was
like late at night and I'd be like shoot
but now you can put it into your music
channel it all in there yeah I don't
know how I just got water in my eye I
know the second EP that I want to do I
want it to be like a relationship type
album okay I also want one of the songs
actually I don't want to tell us
somewhere else go do it never mind I
love oversharing but I forget that I
can't over share in public I'm like a
public thing no we know that you have
plans for things okay here's our final
question if you weren't doing YouTube
what would you be doing instead I'd be a
vet really yeah I was like it up until
like eleventh grade like literally
up until like from birth to 11th grade
yeah I was like dedicated to be a vet
like instead of reading like Harry
Potter I'd read like full veterinary
medical books like I know how to do CPR
on a goldfish or like any fish for the
matter Wow um yeah I would definitely
would want to be a vet I mean you have
all these llamas yeah I mean I didn't
get to one of the books that showed
llamas I was still like starting I think
I'd like 9 or 10 veterinary medical
books that I've already read like 6 or 7
times each cheese
there's still time now I guess yeah it
would just be a lot of schooling and
because I didn't go to college like it
might be hard to get into a veterinary
medical school that's fair yeah but you
know I feel like you have the tenacity
and the drive to just get yourself
YouTube thing doesn't work out or what I
can do I guess I can like buy a
veterinary medical office and then just
like watch all the vets and be like yeah
maybe I don't even need maybe I could
finagle it
there's probably YouTube videos out
there teaching you how to be a vet
hopefully not that seem problematic
Rachel thank you so much for being here
this was super fun before you go every
guest that makes time for us gets a
personalized fortune cookie from us
sterling right the message we there
might be something special inside there
for you if you want to open it and read
it it's not a little towel what did you
do to this fortune cookie
nothing bad we just personalized it it's
this gonna be is this is this gonna be a
pun pun on this cookie no no there won't
be I forget what it actually said I
believe them right now if it's a pun no
I don't think it's a pun
do you hate puns you know I think that
when a pun is really good you just gotta
leave yeah you gotta just be like call
it a day or like you know if someone
says like you know that you did it
really good part whatever around you is
just like oh my god a collective groan
yeah the fortune cookie first you don't
have to okay it says oh it's long how
long are the pieces of paper that you've
never seen a fortune cookie this long
yeah we like to do a lot of things
differently here and I respect that
thank you it says there's a lot of
triangles near make a brand we have no
choice but to say to be Illuminati
yeah
you know I didn't even consider that
it's like a thing really yeah well we
stand either way hey Rachel where can
people find you your music the makeup
everything if they don't know you can
find me at youtube.com slash
rclbeauty101 and I guess everywhere else
if you wanted a look of art should be
doing one from the makeup brand you
could find it on Instagram at our cloak
asthmatics or our coal cosmetics calm
and for the music you just look up rh11
on spotify cuz apparently I'm the only
Rachel Levin on Spotify wow is that wild
that is why I had no like six Rachel
Evans I'm like - Rachel Claire Levin's
because it's such a standard just like
name I'm just shocked that there's not
already told you it's a sign that you
need to be doing that isn't that wild
it's very wild Rachel thank you so much
for being here I learned so much I can't
wait to see more of from the llamas
here's hoping 20 20 more llama content I
will see you guys next time I'm not rep
assertive not too deep goodbye 2deep
2deep 2deep 2deep not too deep is a
production of grace helbig incorporated
producer Melissa D months edited by
Shireen Lonnie Eunice post-production
sound by Chris Henry and an extra
special thanks to Flula for the theme
music have you ever heard of lab-grown
diamonds well lab-grown diamonds are
essentially chemically identical to
natural ones just made in a lab at
lightbox they've cracked the science to
grow gorgeous stones every time so check
them out at lightbox jewelry comm slash
Grace and use the code grace for $25 off